[Music]
foreign you are watching The Press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive in the next
half hour we'll see what's making the
headlines with the journalist and author
Rachel shabby and the editor of the
Jewish Chronicle Jake Wallace Simons so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages for you now well the Metro reports
on the findings of a cross-party group
of MPS that the BBC chairman Richard
Sharp wasn't sufficiently transparent
about his dealings with Boris Johnson in
the lead-up to his appointment
the mail describes a summit attended by
both remain and leave supporting MPS as
a secret plot to unravel brexit
according to the financial times
Taiwanese officials have said they're
very accustomed to having Chinese spy
balloons enter their airspace as they
have in the U.S and Canada in recent
days
the eye hears that Rishi sunak could
soon face a rebellion from within his
own conservative ranks over the
government's handling of sewage in
rivers
the times meanwhile says water companies
are to escape the threat of big fines
over the issue
the Prime Minister offers his thanks to
some readers who've raised a million
pounds for victims of the earthquakes in
turkey and Syria
the express leads with what it calls a
damning report into a deepening care
crisis which is leaving desperate
pensioners struggling to get the support
they need
the guardian carries criticism from
labor over how the government spends its
own in-house expenses allegedly using
taxpayers money on luxury trips and
meals
and the star tells us that with
temperatures in some parts reaching 15
Celsius the UK will be hotter than Paris
on Tuesday which is Valentine's Day
and reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Rachel shabby and Jake Wallace Simons
welcome to you both let us start with
the metro and there headline it's a
murky business relating to what Rachel
what are they referring to
um it most certainly is they're
referring to Richard Sharp's position as
uh BBC head so this is there's a report
looking into his appointment has just
concluded
um and it is quite a brutal report
um John Nicholson who sits on the cross
Party Committee that looked into this
gave an interview with um Sophie Ridge
this morning who was doing media rounds
and and that interview is worth looking
at in full I think because he was saying
look the the Sharp's position is now
completely untenable he's got to go
otherwise he said it looks a bit like
Banana Republic so just a reminder he um
sharp helped to facilitate a loan for
Boris Johnson when he was prime minister
eight hundred thousand pound loan uh
just before being made chair of the BBC
he didn't mention that
in his job application for the BBC he
didn't think it was important
um it clearly is important it clearly is
corrupt and it's hard to argue that he's
capable of deciding BBC impartiality
given all this and indeed John Nicholson
MP did say that he's been deluged with
messages from BBC staff uh expressing
exactly that that it now brings the BBC
into disrepute and hence makes Sharp's
position untenable yes Mr Sharp does say
that that he did follow all the rules
but Shadow cabinet minister Alicia nandi
is saying that cronyism is dragging down
the BBC
um others have said that his position is
untenable but but who is responsible for
telling him to go or otherwise Jake
well I mean you're right Richard Sharp
himself maintains that he did nothing
wrong and that he's innocent of any
accusations of cronyism uh whichever way
you look at it from the outside it
doesn't look great uh the fact that he
uh you know
um helps to arrange this loan for Boris
Johnson then was appointed chairman of
the BBC shortly afterwards but I think
that also it's important to recognize
um that Richard Sharp has been a
lightning rod for criticism since he
took over at the BBC because he's from
the rights not from the left and so he's
always going to be a target for people
who are politically motivated to try to
bring him down both within the BBC and I
sat outside of it I don't mean suggest
that um that you know sort of come out
and defend uh the allegations that's for
him to do not for me but I would simply
put it in political context because it's
a very uh you know important and
significant job to be chairman of the
BBC and he's not your normal candidate
who would normally take the job
do you think he should quit
well I don't know that's for him to to
decide I mean it's very difficult to to
judge when he's maintaining his
innocence as he is but uh certainly
um as a result of the mounting pressure
is going to be hard for him to sustain
his position if it continues but let's
just see what happens over the next uh
day and and the coming weeks uh and to
see whether he can ride out the storm
and carry on we shall see indeed let's
move to the mail and this um very
interesting story about a brexit summit
um Lord froster is warning that it's a
plot to undermine brexit after leading
remain has held a secret Summit on EU
relations take us into this store Rachel
yeah I feel like I've read that headline
plot to undermine brexit a gazillion
times during the good old brexit years I
mean it's the classic sort of betrayal
narrative that
um the sort of extreme uh brexit
supporters have always had and so there
was a there was a cross-party meeting
the other day where
um and a secret meeting but it was
reported where members literally cross
party gathered to say look it's not
working clearly it's not working I think
we can all agree
um Britain is dawdling and um not coming
out of the pandemic recovery in a way
that is comparable to other G7 countries
it's lagging far behind one of the
reasons for that is cited as brexit and
so this meeting is now being cast by
Lord Frost who is the ultimate brexit
fundamentalist the death definition of a
fundamentalist if you looked it up would
be a picture of Lord Frost someone who
keeps saying oh it's not the brexit has
failed it's just that we haven't done it
properly
um he's saying that that is putting
brexit at risk of betrayal so that's the
story yes Lord Frost is
um saying that this Gathering of
prominent politicians and business
Chiefs and ex-civil servants is showing
a will as he describes it to unravel the
deal that he helped to negotiate with
Brussels Jake
it's a strange story this because it was
broken by The Observer
um on Sunday
um and uh and they reported it as a a
secret-ish summit I suppose it's
difficult to say that it's secret when
so many senior figures attended but uh
it was noticeable for it being
cross-party and also uh containing both
remainers and brexiteers prominent
brexiteers attended including Michael
Gove Michael Howard Nigel Lawson and
others and so really it was a gathering
of very senior figures both both in the
world of politics and business and
government and to discuss how to improve
on our position outside the EU now we've
left how to make a better go of it and
uh that the male and Lord Frost seem to
have come one day late to the story and
to be um blowing it up as if it was a
secret plot to undermine brexit which it
doesn't seem to me that it necessarily
was I think that Rachel's right that um
you know brexit hasn't been a smooth
rise so it ride so far it's been a bumpy
road and it's coincided with the
pandemic and other challenges the energy
Challenge and others which has made life
even more difficult for us but certainly
in my opinion it's succeeded in one way
which is that it's returned largely
um our uh our sovereignty or our ability
to decide uh who rules us and who makes
makes our laws and to vote them out if
they fail to do so that hasn't
completely been rehabilitated yet but
it's largely won in those terms and the
rest of it has got to be has got to be
worked out over the coming years so you
think a bit of a non-story from the mail
then
no I wouldn't say it's a non-story it's
quite a big story I just think that uh
framing it as a plot to undermine brexit
uh seeing whether it was the male doing
it or Lord Frost doing it or whatever
seems to me to be slightly overcooking
it
um you know it was a a meeting of people
across both parties and both sides of
the brexit Divide to see how we can
better make a go of brexit I'm not sure
it was necessarily a plot to undermine
it okay clarified the guardian let's
move on to that newspaper Rachel and
these questions over government expenses
what exactly are we talking about here
yeah so the um um the labor party is
launching this campaign
um effectively looking at Tory uh
conservative ministers
basically living it up at the at the
Public's expense using the public quote
like a cash machine
um and saying that they're using
taxpayer-funded credit cards to spend on
you know luxury travel luxury hotels and
I think this is all this being reported
as a bid to further inflict damage on
the conservatives reputation as you know
being being sound on money and capable
of managing public finances
um I
um oh this one I feel like the labor
party at the
in its
um in its attacks on the conservatives I
feel like they would get more mileage by
sticking to one thing and just hammering
it so I mean it's interesting to me that
we've got a we've got a story in the
guardian as well about another dodgy PPE
contract that the government waved
through its VIP Lane
um after uh the cons then conservative
chair was approached by a local
territory activist and half of the PPE
just under half uh in this 25.8 million
government contract was was unusable I
feel like that is a better line of
attack because it is just such a nakedly
corrupt
story of siphoning public funds during a
time of Crisis during an emergency into
you know the hands of their mates and
Tory donors I feel like you know this
this campaign it may have it may have
value about the conservatives using
public funds as a cash machine but it's
not really
of the same scale or the same Scandal I
think as something like PPE and the VIP
Jay what do you make of this story I
mean the top line is that spending on
government issued credit cards has risen
by uh 70 I believe since 2010.
that's right these are called gpcs or
government procurement cards used by the
Civil Service the front office spends
quite a lot on them because they've got
diplomatic obligations and so on and so
forth but David Cameron when you first
came in uh um pointed them out as an
example of waste at the time the budget
was about 85 million something like that
um that's since risen to 150 almost 150
million pounds that's being spent and
there were some details in the piece
some examples including something like I
don't know one and a half thousand
pounds spent by Liz truss and her
advisors in in um in Jakarta I think at
some restaurants and Richard spending
all his Department spending 3 000 pounds
on pictures for the walls and things
it's quite hard to judge whether these
are legitimate uses of government money
or not in isolation for example we don't
know how many officials Liz trust took
to these restaurants
um and so it's difficult to judge but
overall
um as an example of government waste it
does appear to be pretty compelling
given the fact that it's increased from
85 million in 2010 250 million today
Rachel we've just got under a minute for
this last story in the times water
companies are set to avoid big fines for
spilling sewage into rivers and seas as
ministers fear that multi-million pound
penalties could backfire
um how so how are they going to avoid
these fines well that's right the
context is that the times today is
launching this campaign to Red Britain's
rivers and waterways of pollution sewage
and other forms of pollution and it
joins the eye in this so this like this
double-pronged campaign that is focusing
on pollution in our water which seems
interesting it's gaining momentum and
the worry is that the environment
secretary Teresa coffee she's
um she thinks that the fines imposed on
private auto companies for spilling
sewage into our rivers and it's pretty
horrific uh We've we've seen pictures
from around the country of the level of
pollution and the and the Damage that
this is causing but she says that
they're disproportionate
um and is walking back the plan so
that's why it's happening it's also
happening at the same time that sunac is
facing a rebellion for wanting to scrap
the laws EU laws um this brexit bonfire
he wants to scrap laws that regulate
clean water in the UK and even you know
it faces a house of Law's Rebellion over
that yeah campaign is an opposition
politicians saying that rowing back on
the plan for high fines sends the wrong
signal Rachel and Jake for the moment
thank you we are going to take a break
coming up it appears the U.S and Canada
aren't the only ones to have Chinese spy
balloons in their airspace recently
we'll discuss that and more next
[Music]
thank you
welcome back you are watching The Press
preview still with me Rachel shabby and
Jake Wallace Simons welcome back let us
have a look at the um times first of all
and this story about trussites I think
that's what they called Liz trust
followers um I might just be making that
up but they're insisting that her tax
cutting Manifesto should now be put
before the chancellor once again
Apparently one of the most prominent
insisted yesterday the former prime
minister's mini budget was not to blame
for the market turmoil that forced her
from office
discuss Rachel
so it says it says I
it's to me that they they call
themselves that don't they which is
ah but um equally bizarre is their
insistence so soon after trust was
roundly banished
um from politics after you know
catastrophic havoc and damage to the
economy it's extra three that they're
coming back saying that didn't happen
um so yes that is actually what they're
coming back and saying that load cutting
taxes is is the solution to all
Britain's ills it's worth mentioning
that they're doing this in the context
of you know the last few years seeing
just eye-watering
um uh Gap wealth Gap in this country uh
The Divide between the rich and the poor
is just so Stark and it's also worth
pointing out that the sort of
billion profits brilliant Brown profits
that the likes of you know shell and BP
announced this week in that context you
know raising taxes on the highest
earners would be enough to pay striking
teachers nurses Etc several times over
Jake do you think it's too soon to
broach the subject of tax cuts
I think that uh I mean certainly it was
Liz trusses fault that the markets went
crazy and everything crashed and she was
booted out of office there's no two ways
about that
um but I would also say that she did a
great service to people who argue for
low tax by trying to implement those
ideas in such a cack-handed way the main
thing that she did uh so appallingly was
to have these tax cuts unfunded so to be
funded by borrowing and that really is
the heart of what spooked the markets at
the time but I do think that there is a
very strong argument nevertheless for
taxes to be brought down in a sane and
balanced and proper way in particular
corporation tax which is rising to 25
percent we've already seen it drive
AstraZeneca out of this country
um and is going to drive other companies
out as well we saw Mulberry the store on
Bond Street closing because of the vat
breaks for tourists being closed as well
uh and it just is a fact that taxes in
this country are far far too high
they're the highest they've been for
what 70 years or something and that is
dampening growth and we do need uh
growth if um if the country is going to
go back to Prosperity so I think that
they're they're making a sort of a good
point that we do need tax cuts but we
need to have it in a sane balanced and
uh and proper way
let's talk about the unidentified flying
objects uh four have been in a North
American airspace
um one brought down not so long ago um
obviously bordering Canada as well
this article in Financial Times is
saying that dozens of Chinese military
balloon flights have crossed taiwan's
airspace in recent years and it's
nothing unusual they're saying for them
Rachel
this is quite an interesting story
because according to this report
um taiwan's defense Ministry up until
now and indeed
around a year ago were saying well this
has only happened once in the last year
um and now they're saying no it happens
all the time it's like come very
frequently the last one just a few weeks
ago quote from a Taiwanese officials of
the Chinese balloon so this is quite uh
um and I wonder if you know the
the two uh military balloons that were
shot down have sort of precipitated a
new Candor around the frequency of these
military balloons yeah when he's
airspace yeah it is it is quite
interesting that the turn of events Jake
and one person that was a briefing on
the matter saying that such incursions
were happening on average once a month
that's right I used to live in Taiwan
some time ago and there is a sense of
this malevolent big malevolent neighbor
just existing off the coast that's
always there that's a constant threat
and I think that that's a sense that the
Americans are starting to get as well
and and elsewhere in the west and these
spy balloons if that's what they are do
seem to be reinforcing that there have
been dozens across Taiwan regularly uh
and they've been uh let off by um the
Chinese Air Force or the Chinese rocket
Force whatever whatever that is
um and according to uh defense experts
they're thought to be gathering
um atmospheric data to be used in terms
of when they launch missiles um to make
sure they hit their targets and radar as
well so these do seem to have a very
clear military application it's not just
over Taiwan they've been found also over
Japan and the Philippines and elsewhere
in Southeast Asia and now over the
United States as well although the one
over the United States last week was
particularly large so this obviously is
a um is a big threat from China it's
very worrying and it shows that China is
thinking several steps ahead than we are